hoy sabemos que la luz blanca está hecha
de los siete colores del arco iris pero
como lo descubrimos tal vez ya sabes la
respuesta con prismas los prismas son
usualmente piezas de vidrio que tienen
dos caras triangulares que están
conectadas con tres caras rectangulares
como éstas y seguramente conoces el
famoso experimento que cuando haces
pasar luz blanca a través de un prisma
se divide en los siete colores del arco
iris
la pregunta es si tuviéramos que
realizar este experimento por primera
vez
crees que podríamos concluir con base en
el experimento que la luz blanca está
hecha de siete colores personalmente no
lo creo
sabes que concluiría concluiría que el
prisma está creando los colores piénselo
un poco como alguien podría pensar que
la luz blanca está hecha de siete
colores y que estos tienen inclinaciones
diferentes y que es por eso que
obtenemos coloración así que porque
alguien debería de pensar esto la
opinión popular en aquel entonces era
que la luz blanca era simplemente luz
blanca es decir porque suponer que está
hecha de siete colores es como cualquier
otro color el color blanco es un solo
color pero cuando pasa por el prisma
entonces el prisma está creando los
colores esa era la opinión popular en
aquel
entonces era lo que las personas
concluyen entonces lo que vamos a
explorar en este vídeo es cómo nos damos
cuenta de que el prisma no es el que
genera los colores sino que los colores
ya están presentes en la luz blanca y
que el prisma los descompone con
inclinaciones diferentes se necesita a
un genio para darse cuenta que esta
teoría de que el prisma está creando los
colores es en realidad falsa y ese genio
es isaac newton él creía en el método
científico que significa que si quieres
comprobar si tu teoría es verdadera o
falsa entonces debes de realizar un
experimento esto parece ser obvio en la
actualidad pero anteriormente las
personas no lo hacían
seguían solo su intuición si una
explicación o una teoría era
satisfactoria para ellos entonces la
creerían así que esta teoría de que el
prisma creaba los colores era suficiente
para ellos eso es lo que parece
incluso en este dibujo así que las
personas lo creían
pero newton se preguntaba si podría
realizar un experimento para demostrar
si el prisma estaba creando los colores
o no y uno de los primeros experimentos
que hizo fue poner otro prisma enfrente
por aquí la lógica decía que es el
prisma podía crear colores de la luz
blanca tal vez podría crear distintos
colores del rojo azul verde amarillo y
los otros colores que tenemos así que él
quería comprobar si podía obtener
incluso más colores de estos pero lo que
observó fue que no obtuvo más colores
obtuvo el mismo color de nuevo lo que
significaba que el prisma no podía crear
más colores que estos siete colores esto
hizo que tuviera algunas pequeñas
sospechas sobre esta teoría porque el
prisma solo creaba más colores en la luz
blanca porque no creaba
colores de estos siete colores pero esto
no refuta nuestra teoría cierto tal vez
la luz blanca es especial tal vez solo
cuando haces pasar los blanca por un
prisma empieza a crear estos colores eso
es posible es cierto
así que diseñó un segundo experimento y
éste confirmó sus sospechas el segundo
experimento que hizo fue invertir otro
prisma y mantenerlo en frente del primer
prisma y sabes que obtuvo del otro lado
ahora observó luz blanca
al ver esto inmediatamente se dio cuenta
de que el prisma no estaba creando
colores y que los colores en efecto
están presentes en la luz blanca el
prisma solo la descompone de distinta
manera
fue así que descubrió que realmente la
luz blanca está hecha de siete colores
incluso ahora podemos entender esto si
continuamos este diagrama de rayos así
que veamos si estos dos prismas son
idénticos y están hechos del mismo
material entonces cuando estos rayos de
luz se mueven de este prisma a este otro
no se van a inclinar no se reflejarán
porque se están moviendo en el mismo
medio no están cambiando de medio y por
lo tanto estos rayos de luz continuarán
su camino recto pero cuando los rayos de
luz emergen de este medio entonces
observar podemos tratar todo esto como
un solo medio de lados paralelos y ya
hemos estudiado en vídeos anteriores
todo rayo de luz que emerge de un medio
de lados paralelos
siempre será paralelo al rayo incidente
y con este resultado ahora podemos
dibujar y ver que todos los colores el
azul el rojo etcétera saldrán de manera
paralela es decir podemos dibujar y
verlo de esta forma y esto es lo que
esperamos que se observe pero como
mencioné anteriormente esto no lo vemos
en colores esto aparece como luz blanca
y aquí hay una foto de esto este es un
escenario similar observa la luz que
emerge es blanca
porque se observa blanca bueno ya hemos
hablado de esto en vídeos anteriores la
razón principal se debe a que la luz que
entra no contiene un solo rayo de luz
contiene múltiples rayos de luz un haz
de luz blanca es una colección de rayos
entonces si consideramos un rayo más de
luz blanca este rayo se dividirá en
colores quiero observar el color rojo
emergente se encima con el color azul
del primer rayo de luz lo puedes ver y
de la misma manera si ponemos otro rayo
del 2 blanca en medio tal vez el
amarillo empezará encimarse con el azul
y como todos los colores emergen de
manera paralela entonces podemos
considerar que todos los rayos de luz al
descomponerse finalmente se enciman unos
a otros
y como esto se ve blanco para nosotros
podemos concluir que cuando los colores
se enciman o cuando los colores se
mezclan es cuando aparece de nuevo el
blanco
tal vez de esta forma newton concluyó
que la luz blanca no es un único color
separado ni que el prisma está creando
otros colores el blanco es una
combinación una mezcla de los colores
del arcoíris y tal vez así fue como
newton se dio cuenta de lo que estaba
siendo en realidad el prisma el prisma
descompone la luz y le da diferentes
inclinaciones y por supuesto él realizó
otros experimentos que apoyaron su
argumento otro de sus famosos
experimentos es el disco de newton lo
que hizo fue utilizar un disco dividirlo
en siete partes pintar cada parte de uno
de los siete colores del arcoíris y
girar el disco rápidamente
el esperaba a ver el color blanco
esto es algo que incluso podrías
intentar en casa y podrás ver de nuevo
los blancas lo que confirma que cuando
todos los colores de la luz caen en
nuestros ojos lo percibimos como blanco
así que el blanco está hecho de una
mezcla de los siete colores del arcoiris
lo que quiero resaltar es que aunque los
experimentos realizados por newton
fueron muy sencillos sus conclusiones
fueron innovadoras estas ideas crearon
una revolución científica porque
cambiaron la forma de pensar sobre la
luz y los colores